♪ ♪
>> Greg: IT'S BEEN OVER SIX
WEEKS SINCE THE PARKLAND
SHOOTING.
DURING THAT TIME WE HAVE SEEN
MARCHES, TOWN HALLS, MEDIA
SPECTACLES GREAT AND SMALL.
HEROES AND VILLAINS HAVE BEEN
MADE.
SPOKESPERSONS ANOINTED.
UP UNTIL LAST WEDNESDAY, ONE
PERSON DIDN'T TAKE PART BECAUSE
HE HAD BEEN SHOT FIVE TIMES AS
HE TRIED TO PROTECT HIS
CLASSMATES.
ANTHONY WAS RELEASED FROM THE
HOSPITAL.
SOMEONE NO ONE HAD HEARD FROM
UNTIL NOW.
HE SAVED UPWARDS OF 20 STUDENTS.
HIS ATTORNEY READ A STATEMENT
FROM HIM WHICH CRITICIZED THE
SHERIFF AND OTHERS FOR KNOWING
THAT THE SHOOTER WAS BAD NEWS
BEFORE THE ATTACK BUT STILL DID
NOTHING.
>> BOTH OF YOU FAILED STUDENTS,
TEACHERS, PARENTS ALIKE ON SO
MANY LEVELS.
I WANT TO ASK YOU TODAY TO
PLEASE END YOUR POLICY AND
AGREEMENT YOU WILL NOT ARREST
PEOPLE COMMITTING CRIMES IN OUR
SCHOOLS.
I WANT ALL OF US TO MOVE FORWARD
AND END THE ENVIRONMENT THAT
ALLOWS PEOPLE LIKE NIKOLAS CRUZ
TO FALL THROUGH THE CRACKS.
YOU KNOW HE WAS A PROBLEM YEARS
AGO, AND YOU DID NOTHING.
>> Greg: HE WAS TOO WEAK TO
TALK ABOUT HIS STATEMENT TO A
STRONG.
IT REMINDED US OF THE FACTS.
TONS OF CALLS WERE MADE ABOUT
THE SHOOTER OVER THE YEARS, HE
HAD EMOTIONAL AND DISCIPLINARY
ISSUES BEFORE COMING TO STONEMAN
DOUGLAS.
HE WAS ABUSIVE.
NONTOOK ACTION.
THE STATEMENT MENTIONS THE
PROMISE PROGRAM WHICH ALLOWS
YOUNG CRIMINALS TO AVOID ARREST.
WILL THIS MESSENGER RECEIVE THE
SAME PLATFORM AND SPOTLIGHT THAT
OTHERS RECEIVED?
IT'S A SAD REALITY IN THE WORLD
OF CABLE NEWS.
WE HAVE TO MOVE ON FROM OTHER
TRAGEDIES AWAY.
BUT ANTHONY CANNOT MOVE ON WHICH
IS WHY WE SHOULD PRESS PAUSE AND
LISTEN TO WHAT HE IS TRYING TO
TELL US.
HE CANNOT MOVE ON.
THE FACT THAT SCOTT ISRAEL CAN
IS A DISGRACE.
KIMBERLY, WE HAVE HEARD VERY
LITTLE FROM SCOTT ISRAEL.
HE USED TO SEEK THE SPOTLIGHT.
NOW HE IS UNDER A ROCK.
>> Kimberly: NOW THE FACTS ARE
RAINING DOWN ON HIM.
HE CANNOT ESCAPE THE TRUTH.
TRYING TO BLAME OTHERS,
DEMONIZED THE NRA.
DANA LOESCH, BLAMED PEOPLE AT
THE SCHOOL, BLAMED EVERYBODY
EXCEPT FOR ACCEPTING
RESPONSIBILITY FOR CHOICES HE
COULD HAVE MADE THAT WOULD HAVE
PREVENTED THIS.
WHEN YOU HAVE AUTHORITIES BEEN
CALLED 30 DIFFERENT TIMES TO
NIKOLAS CRUZ'S HOUSE AND NOBODY
DOES ANYTHING, WHAT ELSE DO YOU
WANT SOMEONE TO DO IN TERMS OF
GETTING INVOLVED IN TRYING TO DO
SOMETHING TO PREVENT FUTURE HARM
AND VIOLENCE AND MASSACRE?
IF YOU DON'T LEARN FROM THE
SITUATION, YOU JUST FOCUS ON
GUNS, YOU ARE MISSING THE POINT.
FOR THIS INDIVIDUAL STILL HAVE A
JOB, THE FACT THAT HE HAS NOT
BEEN SUSPENDED AND REMOVED FROM
HIS POSITION TO BE AS
ASTONISHING.
>> Greg: DANA, HIS FATHER
CALLED OUT ISRAEL FOR USING HIS
SON RIGHT AFTER THE SHOOTING IS
A PHOTO OPPORTUNITY.
GAVE HIS DAD $100.
THERE WAS SOMETHING VERY TACKY
AND CRASS ABOUT THIS GUY.
>> Dana: IT'S AMAZING, IT WILL
BE INTERESTING ONCE HE IS STRONG
ENOUGH TO TALK TO HEAR FROM HIM
ABOUT WHAT KIND OF BRAVERY IT
TOOK FOR HIM TO BE ABLE TO STAND
IN FRONT OF THAT GUN AND TAKE
THE BULLETS FOR HIS STUDENTS.
I'M SURE THEY ARE LOOKING
FORWARD TO HIM GETTING BACK TO
SCHOOL.
HE'S A REMARKABLE YOUNG MAN,
VERY INSPIRING.
>> Greg: JUAN, HE CAME FROM
VENEZUELA FOR THIS.
THE IRONY OF LEAVING A PLACE
THAT'S KNOWN FOR INCREDIBLE HIGH
CRIME AND HE WANTED TO BE A
PROFESSIONAL SOCCER PLAYER,
WHICH ISN'T GOING TO HAPPEN.
>> Juan: I HOPE IT DOES
HAPPEN.
I HOPE HE RECOVERS FULLY.
WHAT STRUCK ME WAS I THINK IT IS
SOMETHING FROM THE HEART OF
AMERICAN STUDENTS.
HE SAYS I JUST WANT TO GO TO
SCHOOL AND FEEL SAFE.
I DON'T FEEL SAFE RIGHT NOW
GOING BACK TO SCHOOL, IS WHAT HE
SAID.
TO ME, THAT STRUCK ME AS, THIS
IS NO SPIN.
THIS IS NOT TAKING SIDES.
THIS IS A YOUNG MAN SAYING I
THINK SCHOOL SHOULD BE SAFE AND
I SHOULD FEEL PROTECTED WHEN I
GO TO SCHOOL.
I DO THINK IT'S ABOUT GUNS.
LAST WEEK, THE SHOOTING AT
YOUTUBE, EASY ACCESS TO GUNS.
FROM HIS PERSPECTIVE, EVEN IF WE
NEVER SETTLED THE GUN ARGUMENT
IN THE COUNTRY, KIDS SHOULD BE
ABLE TO FEEL SAFE AND GO TO
SCHOOL.
HE MAKES A STRONG, COMPELLING
POINTS.
THE SHERIFF WENT TO VISIT HIM AT
THE HOSPITAL.
WHEN YOU HEAR THIS, I DON'T
THINK THIS GUY IS JUST UPSET
THAT SHERIFF HASN'T PAID
ATTENTION.
HE IS SAYING THIS DESPITE THAT.
THANK YOU FOR THE VISIT BUT YOU
SHOULD HAVE DONE MORE.
>> Greg: EXACTLY.
HE FELT IT WAS A PHOTO OP.
WHAT SHOULD BE DONE WITH ISRAEL?
>> Jesse: FLORIDA DEPARTMENT
OF LAW ENFORCEMENT HAS AN OPEN
INVESTIGATION.
THEY WILL SUBMIT THEIR FINDINGS
TO GOVERNOR RICK SCOTT AND HE
CAN DETERMINE WHETHER TO FIRE
HIM OR KEEP HIM.
THAT SHOULD BE COMING
MOMENTARILY.
THERE IS A GREAT AMBUSH BY A
LOCAL REPORTER FROM ABC THAT
WENT AND TRACKED CHAIR OF ISRAEL
DOWN AND GOT IN HIS FACE PRETTY
AGGRESSIVELY AND SAID DO YOU
ACCEPT ANY RESPONSIBILITY?
WHAT ARE YOU DOING?
YOU HAVE TO ANSWER TO SOME OF
THIS.
HE WEASELED OUT OF IT AND DIDN'T
LOOK LIKE HE WAS IN CONTROL,
SHERIFF ISRAEL.
AND THEN HE FOLLOWED HIM AND HE
WAS AT A POLITICAL EVENT LATER
THAT DAY.
WITH ALL THE STUFF GOING ON IN
HIS COMMUNITY, HE IS OUT THERE
HOBNOBBING WITH POLITICIANS AND
RAISING MONEY AND POLITICKING.
A LOT OF MISPLACED PRIORITIES.
THE PROMISE PROGRAM, GOT TO GET
RID OF IT.
YOU DON'T WANT TO ARREST A LOT
OF A YOUNG BLACK TEEN URGES AND
HIGH SCHOOL.
THAT'S WHY THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION CAME IN AND
PUSHED HARD.
HURTS THEIR ABILITY TO GET IN
COLLEGE AND THINGS LIKE THAT I
GET THAT.
A CAMPY BLANKET.
THIS GUY, LIKE YOU SAID, HE WAS
ABUSING STUDENTS IN SCHOOL, WAS
SUSPENDED, VIOLENT.
THIS IS A GUY WHO HAD TO OF BEEN
ARRESTED.
IT WOULD HAVE TRIGGERED THE
INABILITY FOR HIM TO PURCHASE A
FIREARM.
FOR CNN TO SHINE A SPOTLIGHT
AWAY FROM ISRAEL AND THEN
TOWARDS THE NRA, IT DOES SUCH A
DISSERVICE TO THE COUNTRY.
THEY SHOULD BE SHINING A
SPOTLIGHT ON THINGS LIKE WHAT
MARCO RUBIO IS DOING.
WE HAVE TALKED ABOUT IT.
I THINK IT IS SOMETHING LIKE THE
GUN PURCHASE RESTRAINING ORDER.
YOU ARE BALANCING THE ABILITY TO
HAVE THE SECOND AMENDMENT WITH
THE AT THE SAME TIME PROTECTING
PUBLIC SAFETY.
IF SOMEONE LOOKS LIKE A NOT, YOU
HAVE A JUDGE ADJUDICATED.
>> Juan: JUDGES AND SOCIAL
SERVICE PEOPLE.
>> Jesse: THEY BLEW IT TOO.
>> Juan: I UNDERSTAND YOU'RE
UPSET WITH ISRAEL BUT I'M
TELLING YOU THERE ARE LOTS OF
PEOPLE WHO HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO ACT AND DIDN'T.
>> Jesse: THE FBI, THE LOCALS.
WHAT DID ISRAEL DO?
HE SET UP A PERIMETER OUTSIDE
THE SCHOOL WHEN THE SHOOTING WAS
GOING ON.
EVERYTHING TELLS YOU YOU GO IN
AND CONFRONT THE SHOOTER.
>> Juan: THAT WASN'T ISRAEL.
>> Jesse: HIS DEPUTIES.
>> Greg: THERE IS A GOFUNDME
PAGE.
A LOT OF THOSE, CHECK THEM OUT,
MAKE SURE THEY ARE REAL.
HIS FINANCIAL SUPPORT FOR THE
FAMILY.
IT HAS RAISED $800,000.